let's talk about the war that is
happening now between Donald Trump and
the intelligence community yesterday we
talked about this story that alleges
Russia has a blackmail file on Trump of
course Donald Trump has admitted that he
was briefed about it however he has
denied the contents of that blackmail
file we've also heard anecdotally from
different people including spokespeople
on the Russian side we've heard from
people on the Trump team etc etc about
the content but what we have
increasingly here I I would call it a
disagreement but it's really more than
that between Donald Trump and the
intelligence community you'll remember
last week Donald Trump said I was
supposed to be briefed about Russian
hacking on Tuesday and now they changed
it on me and it's not happening until
friday and then we heard from
intelligence officials no that's alive
the hearing was always scheduled for
Friday Donald Trump is lying and now we
are hearing from intelligence agencies
that Donald Trump also lied yesterday
during his press conference about the
briefing relating to the supposed
blackmail file the claims of the 35-page
dossier released but released by
BuzzFeed were summarized in a two-page
synopsis Donald Trump was briefed about
that and Barack Obama was briefed about
that and there was a suggestion made
during the press conference that Donald
Trump gave yesterday that its
intelligence agencies that are
responsible for that story going public
Trump went after the US intelligence
agencies saying they're responsible for
leaking quote nonsense to the media this
would be a tremendous blot on their
record he made an allusion to Nazi
Germany etc etc well we have now heard
from the US Director of National
Intelligence James clapper who says no
Donald the intelligence community did
not leak the claims about Russia holding
compromising personal information
compromising financial information the
intelligence community just didn't leak
it and there is major tension Pat here
between Trump and the intelligence
agencies that he will not only be at the
top of the organization
chart for starting in what eight days
but he will be depending on the
briefings of these agencies to make
life-or-death decisions maybe not life
or death for him but for many many
people how is this relationship going to
work yeah and I think by attacking these
agencies he's also doing a very poor job
of separating the leadership from the
folks on the ground because there are
plenty of people in the FBI the CIA who
put their lives on the line every day
and it's going to be seen as very
offensive to them especially coming from
the person who's going to be leading
those organizations in eight days and by
the way for all of the it's totally fake
people that are out there Clapper's
statement now connected with Donald
Trump at the conference yesterday saying
that he was briefed about this this
confirms what the initial story was from
CNN remember Donald Trump saying Oh CNN
your fake news because of the story that
you ran CNN said that Trump and Obama
were briefed about this they never said
the contents of the 35 pages are true
they never even went into the details of
those 35 pages we now have confirmation
from both James clapper and Donald Trump
that the briefing took place nobody's
mentioning Pat that by the way it's not
fake news CNN was exactly right yeah and
in the same way that I think he's
falsely equated some of the more
outrageous parts of that story yeah with
the more credible parts he's also
equated what BuzzFeed reported to what
CNN is reporting drastically different
stories drastically different reports
from BuzzFeed and from CNN thinking more
about this relationship between Trump
and the intelligence community if Trump
needs to decide whether to drone someone
in the middle east and it's all based on
reports from the same people that he
thinks are totally untrustworthy how
does that work how will Donald Trump
decide what's trustworthy and what isn't
is anything about Trump from the
intelligence community unreliable but
any other topics he believes that the
intelligence community is totally
reliable on I mean it's a totally
untenable situation I don't know how you
manage presidential decisions if you're
going in with this opinion of the
intelligence community I think that
could be one of the more silver linings
here though because if there are neo
cons in these intelligence communities
yeah they're trying to sell him award
I'm not saying that's what
Athen with Iraq and the CIA now is that
were to happen maybe he wouldn't take in
that information as seriously this
skepticism of Trump is by Trump is
represented in other areas for example
we did the story about in spite of the
Secret Service being the most
well-trained entity for protecting the
president arguably in the world Trump
still wants his own private security
with a nearly 60 year old head of
security who's beyond the retirement age
for Secret Service agents on the
president's security detail in every
instance it's all backwards right
forcing in a nearly 60 year old security
guard because you don't want just Secret
Service saying that you are going to not
trust the intelligence community unless
you determine that they are trustworthy
based on their record in terms of who
did what in terms of Russian hacking etc
etc we've never really seen anything
like this but for the trumpet it's a
positive thing because for all the
criticisms of Trump that we've levied
over the last year plus there's a sort
of genius in what Trump is done he's
created a narrative where anything crazy
that he does or any lie that he tells is
treated as heroic because his followers
have been trying to believe that media
is lying any departure from protocol
that Trump wants like for example
maintaining his own private security in
addition to Secret Service it's going
your own way Trump won't be coerced by
the establishment there's a sort of
brilliant that Trump has set up where
anything insane he does many trumpets
will say see that's the independent
thinking that we like yeah even if it
turns out to be counterproductive
because sometimes this private security
will conflict with what the Secret
Service is doing yeah and also now he
can't really point to any media
organizations and view them as
trustworthy well Breitbart a frightened
bar after calling dragon and more news
yesterday he then went to Breitbart
we'll have a clip of that a little bit
later i'm on twitter at d pakman the
show's on twitter at david pakman show
we'll take a break and be back with a
lot more after this today's episode of
the david pakman show is brought to you
in part by blue apron blue apron i've
talked about food
deserts before and the lack of available
fresh food in many of these food deserts
and one of the great things about blue
apron is that it can be delivered to
ninety-nine percent of the continental
US and ninety nine point five percent of
food deserts and when you combine that
with the reality that you get the exact
amount of each ingredient required for a
recipe we are talking about reducing
food waste while giving people in many
parts of the country where it's
difficult to access fresh and varied
food access to that fresh and varied
food some of the meals available through
blue apron in January our number one
spicy shrimp and Korean rice cakes with
cabbage I made this last week loved it
very very good also spaghetti squash and
marinara with mushroom and garlic knots
you can try this week's menu for free by
going to blue apron calm / Pakman check
it out try it today